stop the presses
weights 286.
hey guys uh i've played a little bit of
this since we last convened
286. yeah
how many hours how many hours on steam
how many hours
less than a hundred i don't believe that
it's 99.6
hours yeah mine just says 100. when i
look at your profile it says 100
okay it says 99.6 hours for me on that
look i have like 22
or something 23. anyway look it's
convenient because it means weight has
an endless supply of
money and supplies not as much how much
money do you think i have at level 286
you probably have a few thousand don't
you yeah probably if you're smart with
your money
wait hang on okay i thought you guys
would have set the bar higher i've got
about 9k
well i'm level 37 and i have like 1600
bucks so i'm
sort of familiar with how the money in
this game works at least okay i've got
nine thousand two hundred that's a lot
considering you only need about a
thousand dollars worth of gear to fully
outfit
four players i mean for as much as i
played you think i have more
but being as everyone always like wait
you're the high level bring all of your
[ __ ] then when i die it's like fifteen
hundred dollars worth of stuff
all your [ __ ] yeah bring all your [ __ ]
wait i'm gonna bring everything this
round because it's like two thousand
dollars worth of stuff then i'll die
throw a hissy fit and make you guys
bring it next round
okay there's also an audio bug so
whenever i give you guys a countdown
like hey guys i'm pressing start
don't press v to talk or else you can
glitch out your audio to where we can't
hear you or you can't hear us for the
whole game
so don't talk now yeah okay let us know
when you're doing it
now okay just okay good hello
hello how are you can i talk now yeah
yeah we're good um
i'm a little i'm glad we went to just
like a farmhouse first i almost looked
like the high school the asylum but if
bob's gonna take that long to load in i
might try to avoid the bigger places
yeah you know i don't like the bigger
places anyway they're too big apparently
they're working on three new maps a
prison
a mansion and like an apartment building
i think well they better hurry up
people are looking for the content when
they're level 286.
yeah i've heard that they might be one
of them i just got a note from the chat
and it's amazing it's amazing non-uh
equipment objects in the world
to communicate is bob's voice yeah his
heart is going a little weird yeah
waits wait yeah there's an audio bug at
the start of the round that makes people
sound like they're on helium
and it slowly goes back so it's gonna
continue to go
down did you intentionally sound like
you were on helium as you said the word
helium
no i'm talking completely normally right
now okay
good it's just an audiobook that happens
sometimes see now you're back to normal
for me wade you just sound okay good
um oh no
i still don't really know they've added
the transatlantic
new ghost since we last played the new
objective is we actually have get a
ghost to walk through salt
oh that's cool yeah so they are adding
pieces which i'm really happy about
are we doing someone in the bus or are
we all going hand in there
it's just a farmhouse it's not a giant
location so it doesn't matter we do have
to be alone so
whatever you guys want to do let's do it
let's get in there let's mix it up let's
get in there
which one's the motion sensor i forget
the two lights one
the blue one okay there's another emf
here and there's two thermometers up
here still
took a thermometer we're gonna mix it
all up
[Laughter]
we're gonna mix it up
and i know it's hilarious it is really
funny okay
i'm gonna confuse which one of you is
wade and which one okay bob you're with
me
are we the same character model yeah are
you brown brown jacket
man am i brown jacket man yeah we're
both proud you're a lady
you're white shirtless never mind okay
cool
hello is that you a radio check their
big uh big man in the truck uh radio
working fine sorry i had to adjust
something on the stream all good now
coming in sounds good
if you only need the first neighbor
what mark do you only need the first
name or do you need the last name too
how would i know ask mr 286 hours
do you guys have a photo camera i do
i found the bone if you want a picture
and pick up the bone oh
yeah you know i do
what did you just throw and then wha
what
the hell there's voodoo dolls on
somebody
don't even else is it what
is that normal i spy the bone
fun have we interacted with a ouija
board together
i have not no once maybe
or maybe that was with you i'll take a
look around so i can find the ouija
board
not getting a whole lot of nothing oh
bob had single digits upstairs mark i
think it's upstairs okay yeah yeah i
think this is the ghost room guys
roger that coming upstairs who give this
kid a gun
what kid had a gun and the painting down
there the kid has a gun i don't know who
gave it to him this room here
yeah this room so uh the over here to
the left this closet
is where it's colder
[Music]
it's still like five celsius so i put
the motion sensor in here so uh that
exists
i'm gonna go down get the camera set up
a tripod camera in here all right cool
action i don't see the ouija board down
here unfortunately it might be up in
this room
i've heard a rumor i don't know if it's
true or not but i've heard if your ghost
is actually a phantom
and you use the ouija board there's like
a way or a chance you can be possessed
by the phantom i don't know what that
means or if it's true or just people
talking
whatever i hope it's true rumors always
circulate about these things doesn't
mean it's true
heck we don't even know if there's
actually a haunting here could just be
you know
someone being paranoid all right i'm
gonna set the camera
across the room from the back i guess
all right sounds good i'll go check the
the truck don't die
all right i'm looking at the cameras i
think i've got one of you
uh whoever's got the thermometer is the
camera upstairs working
uh not as of yet
uh nothing oh my god hello it was
definitely on hello
hi yo i just got out of here it should
be the last camera
okay yeah the tripod camera's working
was that an orb i saw an orb
is that the only uh evidence we've
gotten so far so far that's all we got
do we have a spirit box or should i
bring the sphere box in to uh suck it
out
uh journal and emf i'm gonna get a spare
box
and uh maybe like a uh
i'll get the salt i'll get the salt wait
what
them that might have been weird
yeah it was walking out the doors
towards you
activity is out of ten but the door's
not locked up oh my god
i literally heard the motion sensor boop
so i went to look at the camera and
the ghost was just standing in front of
the camera like just
waiting all right i'm gonna go put some
salt down
uh what's the activity at right now
okay sounds good i'll put some salt down
right in the middle of that room where i
i we saw that ghost photograph walking
right
i do yes oh we actually didn't get
detected
ghost presence with a motion sensor even
though i swear that's what happened
i'll move it a bit
go go oh my god oh my god oh my oh my
god
[Music]
oh
it was it was right there it was right
in front of me wait did you do that
there was a door close all i did was
come in and open the door
okay that was an open door and it closed
for right behind mark when he went in
it was right in front of me i think i
got a picture of it
we just got motion in front of it
did we get it on the board well that
actually might be weight but anyway we
got the motion sensor uh objective so
oh my god we just got ghost watchers
salt and crucifix
okay well that's great crucifix mean it
was trying to hunt right now so it's
angry is our sanity low
no mark at 42 wave you're 24 but
that's not that okay yeah they tried to
kill us just now mark oh that's mean
i'm gonna i'm gonna spirit box it okay
did they did we bring a journal in there
did we bring a journal yeah i'll check
that i'll go in
i'm bringing in the uv light the demon
light see if we can find anything with
that
yeah good call a good call is going off
right now
uh not much activity
f4 currently four
nothing on cams you look clear so far
i'm watching your back bob
uh you look clear so i don't know i'm
gonna give up on spirit box
and try and wander around a little bit
because it was literally
yeah still nothing i'm seeing so i guess
you're clear what other thing could we
do
i'm looking for fingerprints nothing
fingerprints are really tough in this
room that looks like the door
only other evidence is fingerprints
freezing temperatures
uh emf uh spirit box well you you said i
haven't looked you said ghostwriting
right there's ghostwriting
ghostwriting confirmed yeah so we have
two others i'm gonna take a picture of
that
because that counts as interactive you
get a picture of emf while it's lit up
or
the book when there's writing in it
counts as interactions extra money did
you get the spirit box are you doing
spirit box right now
i got nothing on it right now i'm gonna
drop the emf back down and do the spirit
box
it has to be a shade or a ure i still
have pronounced that so we either have
to get
freezing temps or emf5 it has to be one
of those two
yeah well it's calmed down quite a bit
there's not even a blip of activity on
the radar
it literally has to be emf or freezing
temps i guess i'll come back
in all right
what's up bob
oh oh
hello door's locked
oh oh oh i thought i saw something
where is it behind me
oh that's great man don't come to me
take one for the team
oh whoa i see it oh why is it coming to
me
[Music]
no thank you i'm in a corner
[Applause]
damn them damn them to hell
i am
okay
oh [ __ ] no yeah i hope you die
guys hope you die hope you die
mean this is moderately entertaining but
i'm
curious as to if there's a greater
purpose to this
this is below this is baloney
lot of money for bob and i is an emf is
it amf
so much experience too all the levels
i'm going to get busy
for you i hope you're happy for me
he threw a plate
hundreds of dollars why did i die
why me i i don't know
i had nothing to do with that bob wasn't
even like hiding in a room
no i was in the ghost room i just went
out the door and went to the left a
little and was like
okay yeah i came after me i closed the
door and it's just like
beeline for martial i know i
accidentally got stuck in the corner of
the kitchen there i
was trying to go out the door and i was
like oh [ __ ] well i hope it doesn't get
me
and then it got me and also being a
ghost and throwing stuff around is only
moderately amusing i didn't know that
was a feature and uh d-live died and i
was hiding in a bathroom from the ghost
and all of a sudden this teddy bear just
landed on the toilet in front of me
freaked me the [ __ ] out
had no way you like carry stuff around
or could you just like yeah yeah
i could think like one thing or
something yeah just one thing so it
really wasn't that
that involved but uh yeah wow but you
can pick up an object to personify you
yeah sure i got a plate what does that
mean it means you're a whiny complaining
piece of garbage
that is not something a friend would say
to a friend
you know what you're right and i'm not
sorry but i'll reconsider my actions
next time it comes up
that's all i can hope for 288 you got
two levels out of that
yeah i did but
but i didn't get any levels is it
because i died
hey friends hey i was just mocking you
sir i know i know i know
i know but but feelings my feelings
butt feelings you got a lot of blood
feelings yeah i got a sensitive butt
what of it
i didn't uh yeah it's what i thought i'm
gonna press
you better press start and i'm not gonna
touch the talk button telling us we
should stop talking
okay well yeah helium they took a
picture of my dead body
they took a picture of my dead body oh
you and me again
yep sounds good did you guys take a
picture of my dead body when i was dead
did you did you guys pick
take a picture of my dad but for some
reason it didn't count as it didn't
say dead body but on professional hunts
you don't get insurance money anyway so
that doesn't really make a difference
see isn't it awesome yeah
[Laughter]
why do we only have one oh because i
lost
all my crap i literally dumped
everything into the last round that i
had
i'll take i'll take spirit box you guys
take em for indoor thermometer i'm gonna
take photo camera and emph
uh i'll get do we need a salt or a
crucifix one for this one
no just uh motion sensor ghost photo
so two photos and a motion sensor okay
together i got the video camera set up
in there
oh this is the other farmhouse okay
dorothy are you here kansas anymore
oh wait speaking of laughs and if
they're correct did you guys see that
crazy ass
wind of god guy laughing oh my god yeah
[Laughter]
and my soul died it went on for a
straight
minute
like this guy was just like if if there
was any proof that like people can get
possessed it's oddly enough that guy
just
[Laughter]
i don't think that guy took a breath
once in the entire lash meal
well he's basically a corpse that's been
reanimated
nothing on spirit box yet okay cool
what do you want i got a bone i
photographed it and
mark
it was by the way i did not want your
door by the way
okay well the ghost just totally jangled
my door anyway
spirit
[Music]
what are the keys for opening up
different doors or sometimes
car alarms can go off so you need the
car keys to turn off the car alarm stuff
like that
sounds fake
i was lying to you i got him five
why again not me i'm going down i'm
going now can i jump down i can't jump
down
no not like this please
that was incredibly entertaining thank
you so much i really appreciate
why me it went past you and i both and
feline for
screaming at us through the space-time
where are they where are these jerks yes
it's an oni mark
ghost riding spirit box emf5
i'm gonna do one pass in the house with
the camera and just see if there's dirty
water
and if there's not much i'm gonna toss
crucifixes in the room to buy
us some time
in my face i can't believe
it killed him it tried so
hard specifically to avoid us and go for
work
you must be painted in the ghost
community that's all i have to say about
that
did you make fun of ghosts in some
irredeemable way
that's correct throw something at me
take this [ __ ]
oh my [ __ ] [ __ ] all over your face [ __ ]
mark
i'll help you with my [ __ ] stop
following me around with a tube
here's his flashlight it's way far away
from his body
look at me you will see [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
what's the matter
you are really good at handling that
calling
all right i got a picture of the idiot's
dead boss
i mean our friends dead body i'll be
right behind you
don't want to make mark wait around
since he's all dead and stuff
mark it's an oni and oni killed you
you were killed by an oni [ __ ]
i took a picture of a toilet it's not
exactly full of water but it's very
dirty i got a picture of mark's floating
caulk
i'm gonna close the door now hope you
boys have phony
this is [ __ ] this is [ __ ] this
is [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] it's [ __ ] why me
why why me it honestly
it looked right at wade and i standing
in the open
and chose to walk away i know he should
have been so dead and i was upstairs
he should have been so it'll come around
and i'll drop down this dropping to the
stairs there and i was like oh invisible
wall i can't jump down
two inches ah [ __ ] and then i was stuck
but it's okay
i learned how to juggle caulk did you
get a nice pick of me being dead
yep there i am look at you
well i guess i'll buy more stuff
it's okay mark we get so much money for
completing these yeah i know i'm getting
rich
i'm gonna press start now all right oh
hey you and me loading and that's weird
yeah hey can you take one for the team
this time and die not me
we tried our best we stood on it we were
taunting it and it just
went up to the attic and killed you
that's great
any advice hide better closed doors okay
thanks man i was in the attic there's no
door to the exposed area okay
there's no door to the attic so maybe
don't be in places where there's not
safety
in fact maybe don't even go in the house
just stay out here the whole time no
you know what no all right i gave you my
advice it's up to you not to use that's
fine can you sign here just to confirm
that i gave you the property you're not
holding anything
i will take that as a yes thank you very
much appreciate it all right cool
bob oh hey there he is hello
all right what are we doing what are we
doing what do we got well it's a high
school right so it's a pretty big one
we need to smudge the area we need to
crucifix it
we need a photo of it we gotta find it
first so we just need a normal
betty davis together we can be together
for this um the nice thing about the
high school is generally speaking if the
ghost is in a room with the phone the
phone really helps you find it but uh
huh we'll see what's going on we have a
really awful
let's do this let's do this yeah all
right
camera i spent a lot of money on those
mark uh
i don't know who you're talking to i'm
talking to you
more i don't know that's not my name i
took a thermometer so far that's all
i've got thermometer emf
spirit box i could spirit box this time
i got two empty hands you could emf if
you wanted to or um
look obviously look we need a photo
camera yeah all right i'll bring the
i'll bring
actually i'll bring a tripod camera in
so we can get away if we need it does
anyone have a book yet
no i'll grab the book we're not going to
have a photo camera early but that's
okay
yeah we'll get one later we'll know
what's up later
i'm mocking you i'm not mocking you i'm
just doing a bit
okay sure do i just say its name or
whatever what was the name dorothy
no that was the last one david how old
are you
are you here okay don't say that if you
wanted
to answer you only said to piss it off
sure where are you
where are you how tall are you
can you dunk which spice girl do you
identify as
does bruno mars is gay i've got i just
went down to nine
where was this temperature differential
uh it's in the back of the building to
the right of the basketball hoop
uh the basketball room what's that
called uh i don't know wait
wait please tell me that was you and not
a demon okay
yeah the courtroom right of course
yeah i'm looking right at you i'm right
here
uh-huh i went through this doorway okay
how many fingers am i holding up only
one the middle ones
oh man how much wood would a woodchuck
chuck if a woodchuck could chuck wood
69 baby is it possible it's upstairs
what's two plus two i got nothing here
might just not be spirit box though
charlie charlie are you there charlie
charlie
are you there
[Music]
getting a whole lot of nothing on this
thing
maybe it's that same spot whoa footstep
i heard a big footstep right next to me
are you here well yeah yeah yeah i heard
that
hey i'm so scared coming back with a
crucifix yeah
if you say like oh i'm scared i'm gonna
hide apparently that triggers the ghost
to be more aggressive as well so why why
would we
why would we want that why would we god
because i'm so afraid
yeah why would we want that i'm utterly
marmaladed you think it's right here no
we're just hanging out
yeah we're saying we did hear footsteps
clomping around
are you upstairs are you a little [ __ ]
baby a little [ __ ] pissed baby huh you
gonna piss your pants you little piss
baby
you want to drink some piss huh piss
baby one drink some piss
huh piss ghost oh no drowned in piss the
little piss baby ghost
huh luke this baby goes
guys there's no ghost it's a false alarm
[Applause]
oh
yeah i think this is a bust i know ghost
and that was basically a meeting
yeah pretty much the ghost mate stupid
question i'm sorry who am i i
don't
degrees in the middle of that closet but
like
all right this this spear box is bust
i'm gonna go back and get something else
wait is it a solo one or is it a
together one
i just heard something in my own room so
oh well that's not good
do you
don't get away from me you can't wait
for me your bastard come over here i
don't want to come over there
i really need your help with this i
don't need it close the door i'm okay
oh my god it's coming to be you bastard
please
listen i need your help
[Music]
bob i swear to goodness if i didn't know
any better i thought you were trying to
kill me
so that's spawned in the gymnasium right
yeah
that is where we heard the footy
steppies you all right buddy
yeah i'm fine i don't mean to laugh at
your
uh your poor luck there but man did that
really save my life
uh well you know um
yeah this is a gymnasium ghost it'll be
the first one i've
do you need a lighter with the smudge
sticks do you need both yeah
that's correct that's annoying
all right i brought smudge
what was that what did you guys hear
something
it's walking around right now oh it's
existing right now wait don't go over
there should i smudge
i'm gonna smudge yeah i don't have a i
don't have a
photo camera at the moment
i'm going i'm going i'm going smudge
be gone little piss baby little piss
baby
it's out this is the weirdest ghost i've
never had one that acts like this before
what's the name what's the name what's
the name betty betty betsy i think it
was betty davis
eddie davis betty davis i'm so scared
betty davis betty davis you little
pissed baby i'm so scared of you
so that's useless now this is gonna be a
really long room
oh oh hey hi betty davis oh hey
you guys seeing this you guys seeing
betty davis here
[Music]
you guys am i oh she wasn't hunting she
was just haunting so i got a good photo
oh good good yeah that's fine
mark you seem like you're a little bit
like worried when you see a ghost coming
towards you
yeah you know yeah it's weird you know i
see a ghost coming towards me i think my
life is about to come to an end but you
know who am i to think that
it sounds like somebody's making it all
about oh okay
no no oh no
i hear it i hear something
uh what do we do i want to get one of
these rooms why what
this one room and close the door sure
anything else i need to do no i'll try
to lead it away from you
sure yeah okay i believe that yeah i
definitely will she's here
okay hi run
come on betty whoa dead benny babylam
come get me betty family gonna kill me
betty
family
is it over all good guys we have a ghost
orb we totally have a ghost oh good we
got one
of the one of the piece cameras your
camera's not seeing anything
[ __ ] is that in the gymnasium so it
isn't in the middle of the gymnasium
yeah
okay so we should move the stuff to the
middle there i don't think because uh
she i was definitely her i was really
afraid she was gonna turn around go kill
mark again not gonna lie
boo um let's see
so i wasn't able to smudge unfortunately
again i don't trust myself i think the
spirit box is where it's at this spirit
box is definitely where it's at
is there a possibility that spawns too
high that we could reach i'm gonna go
for right the center maybe right in the
center
maybe uh you're right under the orb
right now is anyone there
oh oh we got spirit box who's next
how old are you it's a kid
even though it looked like an old lady
are you angry
do you drink piss do you like to drink
piss
where are you far
what does it mean when it said far that
means it's not here
oh well okay that's good right
uh sure
what's that sound we've got to get emf 5
freezing temps or fingerprints
fingerprints in here
oh look
what is that sound do you guys not hear
whispering
like right now you're hearing whispering
in game i was oh we got fingerprints
right here on the door we got
fingerprints and girls
okay do any of you have another smudge
stick
no no i think we used to both up
hey listen no
there's only there's none left in there
so i didn't grab one so
look i'm alive and i want to get stay
alive and get money
i would like daddy davis betty davis
betty davis betty davis betty davis
betty
betty davis i'm so scared betty davis
wait it did not actually wait really oh
my god did it actually
no okay oh okay ah damn it
i was so excited that would have been so
great that would have been so fun
oh did we get pictures wasn't my joke
also funny
no god no he got us no he didn't get me
i'm too smart i appreciated it he got us
he got us
oh but we need pictures of the thing we
should get pictures why do we have any
pictures of the thing why can't we just
go home
mark bring the uv in and let me get
pictures oh
my god i don't wanna i don't wanna i
feel like this is just a trap to get me
killed close to the door
i feel like this is just a trap nothing
bad could happen it's right by the way i
feel like this is a trap to get me
killed
stop it i know that's you i know that's
you
that was a way you going first okay good
betty's pretty slow i wouldn't be too
worried about old betty
is kind of a dumb idiot i'm so scared
i'm going to run to betty like
over here it's on the door here yeah if
you die to betty davis he must be some
kind of
idiot yeah good thing none of us have
what else did you guys need we need to
make her try to attack us but the
crucifix needs to stop or do one of you
guys have any
first effects i've got one where should
i put it where should i put it i put one
right in the center so maybe put between
the center and the door with the
fingerprints are
so if we if we summon her and she walks
over this she's gonna stop right
no it has to prevent her from spawning
oh so if she spawns in right now it
means the crucifix isn't in the right
spot
but in this shitty ass room i don't know
where the hell the right spot this is
the worst
[ __ ] place betty davis sharks in here
before
this is crazy
by we i mean probably mark no not me why
would it be me
that sounds i'm here betty this is over
here that sounds really thumpy why is it
so
funny
betty davis he's this way your victim is
this way
i'll shine my light on him for you
that joke's on you i'm not saying
anything therefore she can't get me
oh no she's coming for you betty
betty davis don't get way to come this
way
wait i'm coming to help you all done i
should actually be dead
well you're not so i'm disappointed gg
easy
lol gg eazy i think we should keep
playing with the crucifix until we get
her
i think she sucks i think you're dumb
and you want someone to die
i think you're a murderer
i think you're a murderer you're
plotting our demise
yeah she must have spawned far away
because she took so long to get to us
are you here are you here
death how did you die
can we kill you oh oh oh
[ __ ] no she's coming back what's
happening
i don't think i don't know the
crucifixes worked she was to the left
she spawned to the left i hear
thump bass oh she's fast oh she's
uh okay
don't don't don't no don't don't even
try don't even try don't even try i
don't want any
yeah yeah what do you mean it's fine
it'll
stop by then no it's fine
mark i think we chose the correct way
yeah i think so too
if if we're both here daddy i'll see
yeah see told ya all done
this ghost is dumb all right where the
hell is she spawning it
back yeah back left i think we can do
this guys i think we just got to keep
pushing our luck i don't even see my
crucifix i threw down
maybe it worked this one right here this
one right here i found i found it
by the door yeah it was right by that
door
maybe in that corner over there but
close there
over here
oh oh there she is over there
oh hey so she's not dangerous there
she's not dangerous
she seems really dangerous unless your
lights flash you she shouldn't be able
to kill you
that she's smart don't worry she's not
dangerous
at all okay i listen to you sensei
you know what you're doing she'll never
kill you
never never kill me ever never no
did you hear that step that was outside
my soul
betty this could be working right now
yeah let me go check the truck i guess
hey you got it oh great come on home
guys come on home
can we smudge that corner we would have
gotten smudge stick
you would have but we don't have any
come on home guys
all right i don't know where bob is but
i'm heading out okay
hi
sorry i'm just used to taking photos of
your dead body i didn't mean to take
that one
uh where's bob oh i'm coming i got
really distracted by this thing
hang on he's right here i see me
no we see you that's unfortunate
that is unfortunate
it's very unfortunate man you hate to
see that
well he's running pretty good i don't
think it's gonna get him
going upstairs interesting yeah really
cutting off his exit strategy but
getting more distance between him and
the ghost might just work
she wasn't able to make it upstairs when
she hunted me so i think that that might
in fact
be yeah old lady ah there she is
okay you did great man you did great all
right
all right i got in my book let's go
shall we
yeah no problem guys
i can't wait till more actual content in
this game i still am pulling for it
i'll say like like they're super active
on twitter like teasing the tiniest
little updates and everything but man we
need some good stuff